[Applause]
happy monday everyone and what a what a
great monday it is
first of all cat tiff is back from her
honeymoon
it's good to see her she looks fantastic
[Laughter]
you can tell she enjoyed her time off
looks like she put on some weight
but also as you know it's my birthday
and like ensure pumping through joe
biden's bladder
the accolades are pouring in
he's an extraordinary man he is
a remarkable human being i love he's a
legend he's a legend he's immensely
talented he's immensely talented he is
very charming talk like a dude you know
he is
such a visionary as a writer he's a very
very very nice guy very polite charming
he's funny he's hilarious so we love him
great broadcaster in short he's a living
legend he's adorable he is he might be
the sexiest man alive come on what he
does with his life and what he's done i
like it
yes
see okay unite everybody and i'd like to
thank everyone at fox for all the great
gifts i received and thank you sean
hannity i love the wheels
and tucker you know i always wanted a
rolex
and thank you brian kilmeade but really
one of your kids
i promise i'll take care of him
but my biggest present of all
brian stelter got a job
and it didn't involve jeffrey tubin's
hand
yes
the unemployed oompa loompa
was hired by harvard to hold discussions
on threats to democracy
i only hope their endowment can afford
the threat to their plumbing
to paraphrase that guy in jaws harvard's
going to need a bigger toilet
but if he gets
but if he gets 20 students that's more
viewers than he had at cnn
but now when teenagers call him on his
lies he can actually fail them
so what makes stelter an expert
qualified to teach at harvard as opposed
to say a stapler or a bag of loose
nickels
he's not but they take care of their own
he was their useful idiot his idea of a
threat to democracy was just a threat to
democrats to brian those threats were
you trump and maybe salads
and really the only occurrency that
threatens them is a meritocracy because
based on merit brian would be working at
taco bell
instead of blocking their drive through
at 8 a.m
just wait like everybody else brian
but you know what they say those who
can't do eat
no it's eat
so first
so first harvard hires de blasio and
then stelter so who's next could it be
alec baldwin
i mean there's a class that will
definitely need a trigger warning
[Laughter]
of course brian's only going to do at
harvard what he did at cnn is push the
message that you guys are dangerous that
you guys are terrorists and he's not
alone if you watched the liberal media
yesterday on september 11th you would
have thought it was 19 members of
mar-a-lago that flew into the twin
towers
if only chuck todd could wonder are we
now as a nation battling a threat from
within a threat equal or greater than
what we faced after 9 11.
we're now as a nation battling a threat
from within is the threat
equal or greater than what we faced
after 9 11. there's an oath that we
always take
which is
to defend and uphold our constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
oh that's like two yoga balls
interviewing each other
[Laughter]
and her answer was emptier than her
pantsuit what is it about pantsuits
kamala hillary michael jackson
when you see someone in a pant suit you
should probably run
and the mainstream media wonders why
people hate the mainstream media it's
because the mainstream media hates you
you might go to church drive a car to
work or ask why your kid's teacher has a
goatee and a vagina
but you're the freak
but this nonsense is easy it's just like
hating the royalty because anything that
poses a challenge to the media's
authority must be crushed if you really
think about what the monarchy
was built on it was built on the backs
of
black and brown people she wore a crown
with pillaged stones from india and
africa and now what you're seeing at
least in the black communities that i'm
a part of
they want reparations
as beloved as she was she also
represented an institution that has a
long and ugly legacy of brutal
colonialism violence and slavery ah who
doesn't
so what's this all have in common well
it's an attempt to destroy any shared
moment because a shared moment competes
with their political opinions but love
or hate the idea of monarchy it's a role
that exists independent of ideology and
provides a measure of calm when things
get rocky it might be nice to have that
here
and maybe we do
good luck uh wedging those asses onto a
throne
but
but england still takes this stuff
seriously did you know that there's a
royal beekeeper who by tradition was
required to notify the palace hive of
the queen's death
i guess they didn't want them to read
about it on buzzfeed
i should have taken that out right
i should have edited that out
but it's too late it's in you guys saw
it and i'm humiliated
but i never got into monarchy the
closest i came was throwing up at a
royals game
[Laughter]
thank god quisenberry loaned me his hat
he played for the royals
but i valued the sentiment that brought
a country together
maybe it's what america might be missing
something that unifies us other than
pornhub and pizza especially in times
when the media and their woke heroes try
to tear us down like a statue of abe
lincoln
maybe america needs its own royalty not
just a president but perhaps a king
perhaps piers morgan was right and he's
an expert in british royalty he might
have the answer
i keep reading that you are now the king
of late night tv that's so in a way
the american monarchy now rests on your
shoulders you are the king
now i'm not sure i can handle the
responsibility of being a king as joe
biden said heavy are the pants that wear
the crown
[Laughter]
but if i do become king i've instituted
a line of succession for the show in
case things don't work out should
anything happen to me the new host will
be hans uh he'd do great i've known him
for years but if he can't fulfill the
duties next up is lars he works out of
my backyard would be a breast of fresh
air and if he fails then you could
always count on cookie butter
he dances downtown
made sense
earlier this afternoon
but again could i handle the
responsibility of being king when i was
10 my parents bought me a goldfish for
my birthday and it was dead before i
blew out the candles
but i know that rather than trying to
split us up it's my role to keep us all
together through laughter humor and my
good looks i offer all the pomp and
splendor of the great royal families but
with less hemophilia
and i'll start unifying by saying that
brian stelter isn't worse than osama bin
laden the only thing he's ever destroyed
is a golden corral bathroom
let's welcome tonight's guests
she's the reason jim acosta's therapist
is driving a new seven series former
senior counselor to president trump
killian conway
he's the reason we're told to mind our
elders host of the larry elder show and
executive producer of uncle tom part 2
larry elder
place in the crowd
he's the only comic who has clubs pay
him in canned goods actor writer and
comedian jamie lissau
and she's back from her honeymoon but
we've yet to find her husband fox news
contributor cat tim
[Applause]
kellyanne so much to cover with this
brilliant monologue that i put together
all by myself but i want to ask you
first who is a bigger bozo stelter and
chuck todd
at this point both of the above just for
equating
january 6 with 9 11. there's no better
evidence that somebody
is affected by trump derangement
syndrome that when they do that imagine
greg being a 20 year old kid who
identifies himself as a republican maybe
even has a red hat that says make
america great again and you listen to
people on a tv
talk about the folks who killed a parent
you never met
21 years ago
and now equates you with the people who
killed your parent that you never met so
al baghdadi suleimani the people who
raped and murdered kayla mueller the
people who beheaded daniel pearl you
don't equate half of america to these
folks based on what they believe and who
they are it's it started out as elitism
and snobbery but now it's becoming
increasingly dangerous and people are
they're not going to put up with that
and to have the vice president united
states be complicit in it
majorca too is is truly regrettable
america too and i just want to say this
here in new york we have about 118 hate
crimes
against jewish men since the beginning
of this year only one spent a moment in
jail
we have
uh domestic terrorism all around us we
have people hate crimes nothing and and
we don't even hear about it and to call
people terrorists
who love the country who believe that
prices are too high crime is too high
and we're too dependent on foreign
dictators because of energy they don't
think putin should be in ukraine just
because they believe a certain thing
they want to be left alone raise their
kids worship god as they want to they
don't want to be denigrated and
castigated by people in the media
and frankly their own president vice
president yeah it's also working
politically for them because they're
dealing with low information voters
speaking of that jamie
you live in alaska can you see
buckingham palace from there
uh
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i'm sorry there's so many what
would you like me to what do you make of
uh the the attacks on the royalty and
the
there's a lot there's a lot there right
and i know people are quick to dismiss
any similarity between 9 11 and january
6th but i would bring to your attention
that they are both dates
i'm wondering if the fourth of july is
connected uh
you're just asking questions
i have to say just because you brought
up brian stelter and i mispronounced his
name every time i'm on your show i
apologize i think i say stelzer
stealther teaching at harvard is it's
ridiculous it's inferior the only way i
support stelter teaching a class at
harvard is at the if at the end of every
lecture
another guy comes in and goes okay
don't do any of that
that was stupid it's so i mean talk
about a soft landing for him it's like
they it's like brian stelter landed on
another brian stelter
is that possible and in closing great i
just want to say i want to say happy
birthday i don't know if you know i just
turned 40 seven years ago
how's it going larry
larry this is your first time on the
show i've been waiting for this forever
it's good to see you say hello to the
black face of white supremacy yes
don't laugh i worked hard for that title
i'm the uh black face of blm we didn't
know that did you
i don't even know if that made sense but
that made sense what do you make of what
do you make of this uh like and this
kind of horrible relativism uh is it
purely a political act and is it working
uh
you know when somebody on the view i
think was sunny hosting even she said
you know for years i've been saying that
donald trump was illegitimate i
shouldn't have said it right and the
reason she did that is because finally
they're realizing their hypocrisy al
gore will still tell you that the
supreme court put george w bush in the
white house for four years the entirety
of president trump's presidency hillary
referred to him as illegitimate and the
election stolen uh stacey abrams still
claims that 2018 her gubernatorial
election in georgia was stolen uh when
kamala harris was on charlemagne the god
charlemagne the god not too arrogant
i thought trump had an ego
she agreed with him when he referred to
trump as illegitimate so they've been
saying it for years nobody shuts them
down nobody cancels them nobody shuts
down their their social media platforms
for spreading the so-called big lie
yeah
that's a good point cat how you doing
great yeah yeah did you enjoy your
honeymoon i did enjoy it we had a lot of
fun but i also think it's good i'm back
to work right because like
usually five nights a week i get
attention from like a whole audience and
then when that's gone and it's just me
and one husband like
what a life as opposed to puts a lot of
pressure on that guy
[Applause]
what of the many elements of this
monologue what struck you as interesting
or important your birthday oh well thank
you
tell me happy birthday and i got you the
greatest present of all me
i'm back yes i don't know i mean the
stel i kind of want to take this delta
class i want to go
good i idea sit there good idea
and just sit there and just hey like
what can i
learn from you as an employed person
with high ratings
it's so funny he got fired for doing a
terrible job in journalism so they're
hiring him to do exactly the same thing
do you think he's actually going to
explore real threats of democracy it's
only going to be about so-called
domestic terrorism wearing red caps yeah
but i'm going to go find out yeah i
think you should and who could stop you
really no
not that guy no you know harvard um
harvard accepts roughly five percent of
its applicants every year and they seem
to accept one hundred percent of the
bill
cast
blasio brian celcher there have been
others yeah and they they go there and
they're given the imprimatur of harvard
and somehow it's meant to wash away
their biases and their and the fact that
they don't have as all these other late
night
comedians
kellyanne i mean after all he's a guy
that said the hunter biden story was
russian disinformation and then after it
turned out it wasn't he denied that he
said it was russian disinformation he's
imminently qualified yeah yeah i just
love that they're letting him sit there
while he figures out his next career
move
that's gonna take a while
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else